[Music]
yes happy Thursday
everybody ah calm
down calm down calm down I
understand all right is the White House
out of order stopping Texas from
defending its border as you may have
noticed the White House is determined to
let as many illegal aliens into the
United States as possible with migrant
mobs as big as the crowds of Gutfeld
fans at Eastern State
[Applause]
Correctional
great stop it all right all right all
right Grandpa Joe even told them to
Surge to the Border like it was a new
slogan for Taco
Bell I would in fact make sure that
there is we immediately surge to the
Border all all those people are seeking
Asylum they deserve to be heard that's
who we are we're a nation says if you
want to flee and you're fleeing
oppression you should come and I kurumba
did they ever listen to him he's been
waving in illegal immigrants like their
kids with freshly washed
hair but doesn't Joe know this Invasion
exhaust America's resources the way he
exhaust the White House
Plumbing after all it wasn't too long
ago when then Senator Joe Biden spoke
against Sanctuary cities here's Joe in
2007 when he could still exit a stage
without two guide dogs and a sherpa roll
it would you allow these cities to
ignore the federal law regarding the
reporting of illegal immigrants and in
fact provide Sanctuary to these
immigrants the reason the cities ignore
the federal law is the fact that there
is no funding at the federal level to
provide for the kind of enforcement at a
federal level you need yes or no would
you allow the city to ignore the federal
law
no of course that was well before Joe
became a spokesman for Life
Alert since then Joe's learned to ignore
a lot of things like the Border crisis
his extra grandchild and the stain
spreading on the front of his
pants but it's not a battle between
Americans and migrants or Republicans
and Democrats it's a fight between a
bloated power hungry federal government
and the states that get screwed bearing
the costs but a few Governors are
fighting back Texas go Greg Abbott and
Florida gov Ronda Sanchez have been
doing a great job of sending illegal
aliens from border states to States
whose policies have Americans fleeing to
well Texas and
Florida Dems keep touting their
Sanctuary cities right they can't shut
up about how caring they are turns out
though there's only so many landscapers
and illegal nannies the elites can
employ before they realize hey these
people want to stick around so now all
they do is whine about the overflowing
migrants they're like bartenders At Last
Call you don't have to go home but you
can't stay here I guess when the
sanctuary is at their doorstep they're
not so selfless are they but I like to
think of it as reverse socialism lefties
demand to share other people's resources
now it's time for them to share the pain
Martha's Vineyard saw a few dozen
migrants and a few days later ship them
all out faster than Amazon Prime
and now Abbott is fighting for his right
to defend his state from this ongoing
Invasion at the southern Border in a
statement from yesterday Abbott said the
federal government has broken the
compact between the United States and
the states the executive branch of the
US has a constitutional duty to enforce
federal laws protecting States including
immigration laws on the books right now
President Biden has refused to enforce
those laws and has even violated them
the result is that he has smashed
records for illegal
immigration yeah that was a lot of words
huh Abbott has invoked Article 1 Section
10 Clause 3 exactly what you said
cat of the Constitution arguing that the
US is being invaded and his state has
the right to act on it and now not only
is Biden ignoring the law he's sending
feds to take down the razor wire set up
along the border which is like the cops
protecting you by removing your windows
and painting help yourselves on the
garage
door earlier this week the Supreme Court
ruled that Biden could do that but
Abbott vows to put the wire back up as
fast as the feds can take it down
because as legal Scholars note Abbott
isn't defying the ruling since the court
didn't order Texas to do or not to do
anything and yet bozos like b or RoR
call this a violation of law but with
his track record the only contest he
hasn't lost yet is Miss Black America
2024 of course dams are terrified that
illegal aliens will hurt themselves
trying to get through the wire but if it
was left up to the Dems they' replace
the wire with Silly String sorry you you
don't keep out Invaders by lining the
border with silk sheets and cocoa butter
and it's incredibly easy to avoid razor
wire I've avoided razor wire every day
of my life you know I've never walked
past an auto repair shop and thought hm
if I can climb through that barbed wire
I can play with that friendly
Pitbull it's always a pitbull you see
these barriers and deterrents are meant
to protect the Border that's what the
border means dummies it's a line
separating two areas and you're not
supposed to cross that line without
permission every country has them and
there are all sorts of laws about it
think of those rubber things you put
down at the supermarket checkout that
separates your Wonderbread and Mayo from
the guy behind you with rice beans and
pig knuckles it clears up immediately
what is yours and what is mine they're
what keeps one area distinct from
another and if you don't think that's
important then listen to Democrats
about cultural
appropriation huh yeah they say all you
all can come over here sleep in our
schools and airports but you better not
wear a sombrero on Cinco
Deo that's that's a barrier but that's
the great thing about being a Democrat
you only need to enforce the stuff you
like case in point Texas rep waen Castro
is telling Biden to take control of the
Texas National Guard hoping to replace
Don't Mess with Texas with bend over for
Biden and now some are calling for Texas
to secede from the US and they have the
experience Texas was its own country
back in the 1800s when it was founded by
ZZ
Top so are we on the brink of another
civil war or will Grandpa Joe just take
a pill and a nap and forget he ever
abdicated his oath of office in the
first place one thing's for sure this
ain't just about Texas once illegal
aliens get into the country they can go
just about anywhere they want do states
have rights or is the president a king
when you're a Democrat it all depends on
who's in power oh no no look look I
agree with that KY waen he was good in
that movie The Joker by the way you know
I went to school with the real Joker
yeah beat him in uh arm wrestling it's a
true story not a joke but there is not
going to be any texit I I got so much of
Mexico north of the border at this point
they're going to call it
Texico it's like Mexico but with oil
wells Black
Gold Texas
Tea
let's
welcome
tonight's he was recently voted guy most
likely to get robbed on the way home Fox
News contributor Tom
shaloo his act is perfect for people who
hate crowds actor writer and comedian
Jamie
lissow she's known for intensity and
lack of bone density New York Times best
selling Au Fox new contributor
cattive and he trims his nose hairs with
a windmill New York Times bestselling
author in former NWA world
champion Tom could this end up devolving
into yet another civil war like the one
you loved so much when it first happened
well Greg I'm telling you I'm so glad
you got the reference I you know when I
send in my Joe Biden videos your young
staff is like oh I think it's funny but
I don't really get the reference and I'm
like Greg will get it yes Texas
te the uh I think this is amazing and
you know going into an election year
this is going to be a very bad look for
the Biden Administration so Abbott's
putting up the the fence and he's going
to keep cutting it down all year they
are literally cutting holes in the
border wall how is this more proof that
the federal government wants to flood
our country with illegal I so yeah this
is going to be a very bad look I don't
think it's necessarily I'm not worried
I'm not angry at Amy con Barrett the I
don't understand really the incres of
the they didn't explain it that well no
they didn't but the thing is I I guess
the federal government has the right to
cut the fence down and Texas can keep
putting it back up so let's see how that
looks going over for the next year they
going to keep cutting it down we'll see
I guess Phil Collins was right about
those illegal
aliens I have no idea what that song was
about
you know Jamie you're used to people
telling you to keep out of their lives
um damn do you see Texas and America
heading towards a divorce much like the
one you
experienced happy New Year W yeah I
wonder which side will be like my wife
and which side will not get
[Laughter]
anything have you guys noticed that
since Biden has talking recently now
that when I watch Tom shaloo do Biden
it's now like Biden's doing an
impression of Tom Shalo it's it's true
like an
[Applause]
exaggerated my uncle lives in Texas and
he was telling me it's just absolute
chass down there but he is very very
against illegal immigration I should say
he does own a shop that only sells razor
wire
um B Biden said he just this afternoon
he was like you look at my record I have
always been in support of closing
borders I've always been a Barnes &
Noble guy
uh I saw that one coming so far away I
just feel like it's it's upset it's the
whole thing's upsetting and I don't know
I I just feel like if if we're going to
put an old guy in office who better to
yell get off my property than Joe Biden
that one was much better yeah they
should have put razor wire around that
joke oh
[Laughter]
cat where do you stand on this you're
you're a states rights lady well it's so
that would be would be an interesting
thing to way to look at it would be the
10th Amendment remember the 10th
Amendment I was just thinking that you
don't know what it is do you the 10th
Amendment Thou shalt not steal to the
nth no it's okay because thank
you so close um because okay so the 10th
Amendment is not a thing anymore even
though it never really went away which
was was that all uh right you know
rights that are not specifically
enumerated in the Constitution they
belong to the states so that there's
really nothing that talks about
migration in the Constitution but then
that would mean that the federal
government wouldn't be able to do
anything about it so it would be
interesting to see what would happen
with that I would like to see the 10th
Amendment make a comeback but I think
that the whole putting up the razor wire
while someone else is taking it down is
just an excellent micro cm of the whole
immigration debate in this entire
country for since I can remember cuz one
I'm not talking about the the people I'm
talking about the government one side
likes to be like you're me and the other
side's like well you're you're stupid
and nothing changes when the system is
completely broken obviously it's so hard
to come here legally and then with I
mean look at the border I don't think I
need to say much more about that um but
and also another microcosm is Joe Biden
saying oh no no way on Sanctuary cities
and then the political climate kind of
changes and you say something else I
don't know how many people actually have
principles or how many people really
care but you know that's I'm pessimistic
about most things he's been on every
side of every issue if you live long
enough you will turn into a hypocrite
every 3 years just keeps coming back
Tyrus okay there are 25 States
supporting Abbott there's a civil war
are we going to be on the same
side not in the first eight
minutes cuz I got to be sure so I might
have to put hands on you a little bit
listen I I think it's a wonderful idea
that the federal government is going to
come in and take out the the razor wired
you know I would like to be sent there
on assignment and all I need is a lawn
chair a little music and a camcorder to
watch these Equity hires kill themselves
trying to take down Bob wire hearing a
grown man complaining about his stiletto
heels or killing him while he's cutting
this and no one's holding his Yorkie is
going to be
hilarious understand who's been working
for the federal
government they're going to have and
someone's going to be up there I am the
first whatever whatever to go cut this
thing and then 4 hours later they are
also the first person to die a fixation
by cutting these wires so let them point
the way please do that's what Joe should
do he should make it a historic first we
have a a a trans non-binary person of
color to cut the razor wire yes that's
exactly what it's going to be then
they're going to hire this is the burn
then going to hire a commission to
investigate why the wire is not
cooperating because everyone knows that
razor Bob wire was made during white
supremacy so therefore there's going to
be a whole racial investigation of the
systemic racism of Bob wire so please
I'll be fine a little chair a cooler
with some beverages yes and a cam
quarter be like yeah you're doing real
good is this they it
up hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else